needed a thank you department at
winelibrary.com my business it's not
gonna christen the head of the Thank You
Department which oh by the way is not
customer service the Thank You
Department is playing offense customer
service on social media is playing
defense so we're playing a little
offense customer comes in a call
Christian I go listen the books about to
come out I need some examples for this
crowd something that's relevant
something that's real and tangible not
me just going up there and saying here
do it customer places an order from
Chicago and we find who he is on Twitter
and then we follow him in the month of
January and here's what we saw Jay
Cutler I love you
Superbowl runs through Chicago [ __ ]
Packers who suck and Rogers are dead
yeah we won today next stop Superbowl
today's the big game oh [ __ ] Jay
Cutler's hurt we're in trouble
crap we lost but I still love you Jay
Cutler okay we took that data so the
data I have in a normal 1995 world was
he likes Barolo and Brunello the
information I have today is what hits
him in the emotional center what he's
willing to put out to the world and what
paints a picture about who he is
so I called Kristen after she sent me
this day and I said Kristen here's what
I want you to do I want you to go to
ebay and I want you to buy a Jay Cutler
signed Jersey and send it to him with a
note saying thank you for your first
order with winelibrary.com
and that was it and that was kind of the
talk I was giving for the first part of
the book to tell people about some of
the things were looking at that
consumers are putting out more data than
ever and we can really leverage that
data to give one-on-one marketing to win
their wallet cuz it's all about lifetime
value not about the spend you get right
now but over the last couple weeks the
story's changed on stage because
something good happened he finally
emailed back and he said hey you know
first of all Kristen thank you so much
you know I'm a hedge fund guy in Chicago
I'm very very busy I got the jersey I
love it it's framed in my office I
didn't have time to write you back
amazing how did you know
but I just want you to know that I've
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
with Sam's in Chicago which is a great
store in Chicago you should shop there
great store I've spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars there but they've
never done anything for me when I walk
in the store they don't even know who I
am this gesture means a lot to me and
count yourself as somebody that I want
to do business with the rest of my life